the Mandalorian has the production
values and watchability of a Star Wars
feature film as well as lots of subtle
references and callbacks to other Star
Wars media here are some Easter eggs
that even the sharpest-eyed Star Wars
fans might have missed in the
Mandalorian the Mandalorian takes place
after the events of the original Star
Wars Trilogy and before the events of
the sequel trilogy there are a lot of
different races from a lot of different
planets interacting in the first episode
and many of them use their own distinct
language in a bar scene at the top of
the first episode a fearsome looking man
with an unruly beard beats up on a
blue-skinned alien the target are
protagonist Bounty Hunter is after look
at his glands I bet we could sell them
at the Port subtitles tell the audience
what the bully says in an alien language
the guy tries to pick a fight with Mando
when he arrives asking if his armor is
Real veskar Steel the language he's
speaking is hatiz the language of the
Huts a Star Wars race made most famous
by Jabba the Hutt in Return of the Jedi
after the Mandalorian captures and carts
off his captured Target to collect the
price on his head in episode 1. The
Prisoner makes small talk with the stoic
silent Bounty Hunter back on his ship he
even notes that he was hoping to be free
for Life day then he stops talking when
he discovers Mando's other bounties
frozen in carbonite just like Han Solo
and The Empire Strikes Back what's life
day it's the Star Wars universe's
equivalent of Christmas a time for
celebrating and relaxing with loved ones
it was first introduced in the Star Wars
holiday special an Infamous 1978
television variety show it follows
Chewbacca's family as they watch
futuristic TV and wait for him to arrive
for Life day the special ends with
Princess Leia singing a life day Carol
life day isn't the only Mandalorian
callback to the Star Wars holiday
special we also see the Title Character
sporting a distinctive weapon that
should be familiar to longtime fans of a
galaxy far far away the prom rifle he
wields at one point during the show it's
a cool looking apparatus with a long
past in Boba Fett's first ever
appearance made during an animated
sequence during the holiday special he's
packing the same weapon it likely
doesn't mean much as far as a connection
to Fett is concerned but it's a Nifty
nod to Star Wars lore episode 2 delivers
even more Vaguely Familiar entries in
the mandalorian's Arsenal during his
battle with the mud horn he fires a
small flamethrower mounted on his arm
that's apparently standard issue Bounty
Hunter gear as both Jango Fett and Boba
Fett have been depicted with one and
various Star Wars media the first
episode of the Mandalorian is filled
with enough alien dudes and monsters to
satisfy any Enthusiast while it would
take too long to list every single alien
who appears in the show it's certainly
worth pointing out one of the most
surprising appearances of the episode
early on when the Mandalorian and his
Bounty are booking passage back to his
ship the razor Crest they encounter an
alien hidden behind a pair of goggles
and and a long snout he plays killer
flute and we never learn his name but he
should be recognizable to any
detail-oriented Star Wars fan this
fellow was a kubas an alien species
who's only shown up one other time over
the course of the Star Wars saga think
back to a New Hope specifically the
scene shortly after Luke and Obi-Wan
meet Han Solo and Chewbacca in the
Alleyways of moss Eisley akuba is named
garandin contacts the Imperial
Stormtroopers patrolling the streets to
let them know that he's found the droids
they're looking for if it's a Star Wars
property you can be guaranteed that it's
going to be swimming and robots or as
they're referred to in the franchise
droids the Mandalorian is full of
bleeping blooping droids in the
foreground and background doing their
jobs and staying out of the way of the
humanoid characters well mostly
oh no
Bounty Droid
in one scene in the first episode The
Mandalorian walks through a Marketplace
one of the objects he walks by is some
kind of red and white R5 Droid it looks
an awful lot like the red and white r5d4
model from Star Wars A New Hope the one
with the explosively bad motivator
another R5 model appears later during
chapter 5 in the Moss Eisley Cantina
when the Mandalorian arrives at the
Fortified headquarters of the client
he's greeted by a round red light
equipped Droid tasked with security and
gatekeeping that looks and sounds just
like the security Droid Jabba the Hutt
used in Return of the Jedi at the front
gate of his Palace until now the
kawakian monkey lizard has had just one
place in live-action Star Wars Canon as
the snickering pet of unsavory
characters like Jabba the Hutt they're
mischievous they're obnoxious they seem
well suited for villainy and they're
apparently delicious immediately after
the Mandalorian gets his Bounty
assignment from the client he walks
through the marketplace of a desolate
looking little town one one alien
species stands out the kawakian monkey
lizard it's rough for him too because
he's being spit roasted while his buddy
looks on horrified from a cage it's a
bit of a horrific sight especially
knowing that these animals are known to
have a pretty well developed sense of
humor while everyone's favorite monkey
lizard salacious B crumb escaped Jabba's
insatiable hunger by having a special
talent for being a goofball these other
creatures weren't so lucky in episode 2
of the Mandalorian the one they call
Mando is keeping the asset safe
throughout a treacherous and violent
Journey this trip includes a run-in with
the Jawas a race very recognizable to
fans of Star Wars films for their hooded
cloaks and glowing eyes the Mandalorian
blasts any that could get in its path
turning them into nothingness as they
poof away without a trace later on quill
tells the Mandalorian that the creatures
really don't seem to like him for some
reason Vando replies well I did
disintegrate a few of them
this calls back to a brief exchange and
The Empire Strikes Back between Darth
Vader and Boba Fett when Vader tells the
Bounty Hunter to bring back the crew of
the Millennium Falcon Vader demands that
Fett bring his Quarry back with no
disintegrations during the evacuation of
Cloud City on bespin and The Empire
Strikes Back a random guy runs into the
frame looking for a way out while
desperately clutching something about
the size and shape of an ice cream maker
nearly 40 years after the release of
Empire the third episode of the
Mandalorian provides a full and
compelling explanation for the Frozen
treat machine the Mandalorian returns to
the client to hand over the asset and to
receive his promised reward akemtono of
the precious metal baskar true to his
word the client hands over the best car
in what looks like an ice cream maker
the Mandalorian is a working man before
he's anything else and while he's in
possession of a tiny adorable yoda-like
creature for the first two episodes he's
also obligated to turn it over to the
Imperials who hired him but Mando isn't
a monster and he just can't bear part
with baby Yoda after having bonded with
and developed an affection for the
little one so Mando attempts to retrieve
the baby and as he looks for him he
spots a piece of metal pipe propped up
against a wall in an alley is that just
a random piece of space junk from this
post-war Galaxy not exactly it's covered
in ridges and Designs recognizable from
a very important piece of random junk in
the original 1977 Star Wars it looks
just like the pipe that Princess Leia
Han Solo and Luke Skywalker used to try
to jam the walls of a trash compactor
they got caught in while the Mandalorian
boasts some star power the true breakout
character is the one colloquially
referred to as baby Yoda just like Mando
himself the little guy has won over our
hearts and his adventures alongside his
Bounty Hunter babysitter take up much of
the show's plot as far as we know this
adorable little creature hasn't been
given a proper name yet the online
community just uses baby Yoda because it
looks and acts like a baby version of
Yoda in the fourth episode of the show
though mando does provide the child with
a nickname womp rat it's a playfully
delivered pet name and one that has
significance in the Star Wars Universe
in Star Wars A New Hope Luke Skywalker
brags to back on his planet of Tatooine
he liked placed a bullseye womp rats in
my t-16 back home they're not much
while some fans May argue on behalf of
the Enterprise the Millennium Falcon is
probably the most famous spaceship in
all of Pop Culture as piloted by Han
Solo and the original Star Wars Trilogy
its agility and Firepower helped the
rebels topple the evil empire and yet
it's an old craft long in the possession
of Lando Calrissian before Han ever had
it and it certainly endured some damage
in numerous conflicts with Imperial
squadrons including Darth Vader himself
speaking of conflicts with the Empire
here's the atst Scout Walker which
attempted to lay ways to Endor in Return
of the Jedi in that movie Lando refers
to the Falcon as a hunk of junk when the
atst makes its triumphant appearance in
episode 5 of the Mandalorian mando takes
a page from Lando's book and calls The
Battered Scout Walker a hunk of junk as
well there's one other fun link between
the Mandalorian and Lando Calrissian the
fourth episode of the Disney plus Star
Wars series was directed by Bryce Dallas
Howard daughter of Ron Howard Ron Howard
was the director of solo a Star Wars
story which features young Lando as a
major character like many planets in the
Star Wars Universe Tatooine has a large
and varied population of droids upon
landing at the planet's Moss Eisley
Spaceport early in the mandalorian's
fifth episode Mando is greeted by a
couple of clumsy pitroids much like the
ones glimpsed in Star Wars Episode 1 The
Phantom Menace in charge of those
pitroids is a spaceship mechanic
overseeing The Landing Bank portrayed by
a comedian Amy Sedaris under a lot of
makeup and a curly wig when Mando heads
into the space for its Watering Hole to
look for work he finds more droids this
is notable because the establishment
once banned mechanical patrons as Luke
Skywalker learned when he tried to enter
with C-3PO now years later droids seem
to be fully welcome there mingling with
the bar's expected variety of alien
races even the hard-working bartender is
a Droid and one of the same model that
Jabba the Hutt used to oversee his
robotic staff back in return to the Jedi
an episode of the Mandalorian involving
Moss Eisley would be remiss if it didn't
include a sequence set in the
spaceport's famous Cantina in chapter 5
delivers inside the place that Obi-Wan
Kenobi once called a wretched Hive of
scum and villity Mando chats with a
young novice Bounty Hunter named Toro
calicon the cocky aloof Young Buck
definitely gives off a Han Solo Vibe but
maybe that's just because he's sitting
alone in a booth in the Cantina with his
feet up on the table Toro isn't hanging
out in the same booth that Han did but
it's very similar and just a few feet
away from the side of one of the most
famous scenes in Star Wars lore Mando
finds some action on Tatooine and he and
his new associate Toro calican pursue
the Fearsome assassin fennec Shand we
see them zooming off across the planet's
desert surface on a couple of speed
meter bikes Anakin Skywalker is seen
riding a similar model and attack of the
Clones just before he kills the group of
Tuscan Raiders that kidnapped his mother
Mando also encounters some of these sand
people approaching with caution to ask
for permission to pass through their
land they get to go ahead and find Shand
armed with a monster of a rifle She's
Got The High Ground she'll wait for us
to make the first move
Mando tells Toro that is a subtle
winking nod to a similar thing that
Obi-Wan Kenobi says to Anakin Skywalker
during their big lightsaber Showdown and
Revenge of the Sith when Kenobi claims
he has The High Ground eventually the
two bounty hunters get the upper hand
and manage to capture Shand they decide
to keep her alive because as Mando says
she's no good to us dead
the phrasing reminds us of something
Mando's fellow mask Bounty Hunter Boba
Fett says Darth Vader in The Empire
Strikes Back when Vader decides to put
Solo in carbonite the Bounty Hunter
reminds the Dark Lord that solo is no
good to me dead the Mandalorian is
welcomed a number of comedians to its
cast and supporting roles and Bill Burr
arrives in chapter 6 The Prisoner the
motor mouth stand up is a perfect fit
for the role of Mayfield part of the
crack mercenary team hired by Mando's
former cohort ransar Rand malk to bust
one of his Pals out of a prison ship on
the way to that gig Mayfield and fellow
Merc Shan addressed the elephant in the
room what exactly Mando looks like under
that helmet Mayfield imbued with Burr's
comic Spirit jokes that Mando must wear
a helmet to hide the fact that he's a
gungan it's a crude reference to
arguably one of the most loathed
characters in all of Star Wars Jar Jar
Binks the goofy gungun who played such a
major role in The Phantom Menace
hmm
the sixth episode of the Mandalorian is
particularly full of appearances by
notable contributors to past Star Wars
media one of the members of the prison
break super group ran assembles is a
devaronian named ERG under all that
makeup is Clancy Brown a character actor
with more than 250 acting credits not
the least of which is voicing Mr Krabs
on SpongeBob SquarePants he's also done
quite a few Star Wars voices including
Darth Maul's brother Savage oppress on
the Clone Wars and rebel leader writer
azandi on Star Wars Rebels another
veteran of the Clone Wars animated
series also pops up in episode 6 that
doomed New Republic trooper on the
prison ship is played by Matt Lanter the
voice of animated Anakin Skywalker
lanter has voiced the man who would be
Darth Vader in more than 100 television
episodes which means he's played the
part more than any other actor the
Mandalorian is full of nods to Star Wars
past whether their tributes to the
original trilogy the prequel trilogy or
Beyond in chapter 6 though the show also
makes time to pay tribute to the people
who made the Mandalorian itself when the
mercenary crew arrives on the prison
ship for the task at hand they walk past
the cell that contains a four-armed
monkey-like creature that belongs to the
ardenian race that species is a
relatively new addition to the Star Wars
Canon the alien first appeared in Solo a
Star Wars story in 2018 in the form of
agile pilot Rio Durant Rio was voiced by
John Favreau the Creator and executive
producer of the Mandalorian those X-Wing
fighters who make an explosive
appearance at the end of the episode are
named jib Dodger sash Kettler and
Trapper wolf they're betrayed by Rick
famuia Dever chow and Dave filoni all of
them directors of various episodes of
the Mandalorian the opening of the
mandalorians first season finale offers
a bit of much-needed comic relief to cut
the high-stakes tension set up by the
last episode it also offers a bit of a
callback to a joke from a previous
episode about a beloved part of Star
Wars lore remember in chapter 6 when the
mercenary Mayfield took offense at being
compared to a stormtrooper it's because
Stormtroopers are notoriously terrible
shots the two speedier bike riding Scout
Troopers shown in episode 8 of the
Mandalorian can't hit anything either
even when firing their blasters in a low
stakes no stress situation they're
firing a feast of debris just because
they're bored and they still can't hit a
thing
in the eighth and final episode of the
mandalorian's first season viewers
finally get an information dump of
background info on the mysterious and
compelling ex-rebel fighter Cara Dune
one major Little Nugget as revealed by
moff Gideon is that the former Rebel
Shock Trooper hails from the planet
Alderaan the home planet of Princess
Leia or at least it was the home of
Princess Leia until it was destroyed by
the Death Star back in Star Wars A New
Hope craving Justice for her people
would have been a pretty motivating
factor for Cara Dune who then decided to
become an active member of the Rebellion
because of her Rebel history Cara also
mentions her fear of getting
interrogated with a mind flare that's
more of a horror fantasy term like
something out of stranger things but in
the Star Wars Universe Cara is most
likely referring to something like the
bore gullet that's the purple-skinned
psychic creature that painfully
interrogated Bodhi rook in Rogue one
it's basically an alien lie detector
while also breaking someone's brain as
it works in a major moment of the
Mandalorian chapter mop Gideon cuts a
path to Freedom out of his downed TIE
fighter with the use of a lightsaber but
this is not just any lightsaber it's a
black lightsaber as it isn't cast in a
customary neon shade this is a very cool
looking Star Wars weapon and also an
instant indication that moff Gideon is
truly a dark force to be feared his dark
saber as well the darksaber the
ceremonial weapon traditionally bestowed
on the leader of Mandalore first forged
by an ancient Mandalorian Jedi it's
popped up throughout the Star Wars
animated Canon it was last seen on Star
Wars Rebels when Rebel fighter Sabine
Wren passed it along to death watch
leader bocatan to more effectively fight
the Empire the fact that mob Gideon now
has this coveted weapon is bad news all
around as he's an imperial die hard that
means good guy or perhaps a lot of good
guys had to die for Gideon to get his
hands on this all poses a lot of
questions which can only be answered by
another season of the Mandalorian check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more Looper videos about Star
Wars are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]